Speaker 1: The other piece of congressional
hearings today involves a little bit of
a prediction that took place a few months
ago by many of the people who do what I do.
And that is as soon as Marjorie Taylor GREENE
gets on a committee, it's going to be chaos
and she's going to not earnestly take the
work seriously. She's going to be someone
who's there to create clips for Newsmax
and Fox News and Oann. And she started off
with the bang. I will say this, though, it's very
clear that she's well, she's obviously a dum dum,
but she's out of practice having not served on
committees for so long in her previous term.
And. Well, let me just set the stage for
you. She's she's questioning Gene Dodaro,
who's the the comptroller general of these United
States and and the head of the US Government
Accountability Office. And Marjorie Taylor GREENE
is asking all these just whacked questions about
whether or not COVID dollars relief money went
to support or went to fund CRT and then other
things. But let's start with just the jackass
story of the concept of this question. Here's
Marjorie Taylor. GREENE Fighting the good fight.
Speaker 3: NOTARO Can you tell me how much how
much COVID cash went to CRT? CRT Critical
Race Theory and Education. It's a racist
curriculum used to teach children that
somehow their white skin is not equal to
black skin and other things that education. Yeah.
Speaker 4: No, I do not know that. But I do know
that there's provisions that the federal funds
generally are not used. They're supposed to be
used for curriculum. Oh, it's a state auditor.
Speaker 3: I have to tell you in Illinois that
they received 5.1 billion. At an elementary school
there that that used it for equity and diversity.
So it's it's being used for these
things asserted error. Can you.
Speaker 1: I mean, of all the summations
that you could hear that try to define
what CRT critical race theory is.
That's what I haven't heard that
they teach that black skin is somehow or
white skin is not as good as black skin.
And then the claim that an elementary school,
a single elementary school in Illinois,
received $5.1 billion in COVID relief to teach
CRT. That's one hell of a COVID curriculum, if
you're asking me. 5.1 billion would fund hundreds
of schools, not just a single elementary schools
curriculum in this specific thing that they're
trying to fearmonger. Critical race theory. Well,
isn't being taught in elementary schools.
Because it is a graduate level critical theory.
It is for law students. It is not
for elementary kids. And it's most
certainly not that black skin is better
than white skin, or white skin isn't as good
as black skin or. Yeah, but see, it's. This is so
stupid. It's even difficult for me. I mean, I am a
bit of a dumb dumb myself, but this is so stupid
that it's even difficult for me to even recite.
So the questioning went on. She's very concerned
about COVID dollars and where they went,
where relief money was spent. She she also is
asking the same man who's a very serious dude,
has a very serious job about the funding with
COVID dollars of drag Queen Story Hour zero.
Speaker 3: Can you tell me how much
money was given to drag Queens story Our.
Speaker 4: That. I'm sorry. Can you repeat that.
Speaker 3: Drag queen story time where where
men dress up as women and read
confusing books to children?
Speaker 4: First, I thought you said dry
clean. So I'm sorry. No, I don't know
the answer to either one of those two are.
Speaker 3: We need to look into this and I
urge you to do that. They Bradberry Sullivan, LGBT
Community Center in Pennsylvania received $16,000
for drag Queen storytime from from COVID cash.
I think this is an issue that needs to be looked
into. A lot of this money went to things that
should have never gone to. And I thank you so
much and I yield back the remainder of my time.
Speaker 1: If only she would permanently
yield back the remainder of her time. I think
America would be better off. Look, if an LGBTQ
community center received COVID funds, it's not
specifically earmarked for drag Queen story hour,
which, by the way, no one is being harmed by
that, whether they read confusing books, she says.
Look. Bring it in, Marge. Bring it in.
Just because you're confused by a book doesn't
mean that book is inherently confusing.
She continued. It's not just CRT. The
dangers of CRT and it's not just, oh,
drag queen story hour. It's also talking about her
own pillow. She wanted to get it on the record in
case it got brought up by someone else. That's all
I can assume. But she's denigrating someone for
taking pipe money. While admitting that she also
took peep money. Make it make sense. Watch this.
Speaker 3: Mr. Chairman, I'd like to bring
up something that was brought up by one of
our Democratic colleagues on this panel about
Republican members of Congress taking up loans.
I never took one as a member of Congress, but
as a business owner, I did take up a loan in
order to be able to pay my employees. And I'm so
thankful I was able to do that because they would
have lost their jobs. And I think it's important
to recognize. But the minority side of our our
committee here is having a witness on the next
panel that had said that she didn't or her or
any of her affiliates take any federal grants
or contracts related to this hearings, subject
matter. But in fact, as executive director of the
National Employment Law Project, they took it they
took over 825,000 and poppy loans from the SBA.
So that that does need to be pointed out about
the next panel witnesses. Here we are, a nation.
Speaker 1: And in her mind, she just leveled a
devastating blow. Remember this tweet from
like August where the White House put up
all of the different congresspeople who were
maligning the forgiveness of student loans,
who took hundreds of thousands and
sometimes millions of dollars in PPE loans.
Yeah, this is a congresswoman. Marjorie Taylor
GREENE had $183,504 in PPE loans forgiven.
So it is the height of hypocrisy. It
is the height of stupidity. And it is
an aggrieved Republican who's looking to take out
their frustrations and vengeance on Democrats, I
guess, but through the American people and also by
not doing their job, they talk about fraud, waste
and abuse so much. It's a common refrain, but
really, the fraud, waste and abuse here in this
case on this segment is Marjorie Taylor GREENE not
doing her job yet, still getting paid to do it.